should you be dating if you're broke I  dated when I was broke I dated when I  had money I mean I think dating is a  human thing and people shouldn't date  when they're broke then the entire  developed World wouldn't procreate I  think what you need to look for is  somebody who believes in you more than  you do and that's rare but you only need  to find one if you keep that bar really  high you can go on lots of dates all  with the intention of finding somebody  who's really going to try and go where  you want to go and they want to get  there the way you want to get there and  I think if you can do those things  you'll ultimately find the right person